[Music]
hello everybody what's going on I was a
[ __ ] terrible intro anyway guess what
today is going to be the very first
episode where yes I'm doing a mukbang
what stop [ __ ] I originally saw the
stuff and I didn't understand what it
was about but it's been really highly
requested that you guys would want to
see me eat which is weird because I've
watched a lot of these month bugs and
usually it's like a pretty girl eating
which is kind of like the interesting
thing like you don't expect this skinny
girl eating a lot of food but now you
just see a fat guy eating food and it's
kind of like yeah it makes sense but in
today's mukbang episode we're going to
be eating three of my favorite favorite
packaged ramen meals now if you never
had packaged ramen obviously your
parents don't love you and have no
friends I'm [ __ ] with you you
probably had nutritious meals but for me
growing up my parents worked so much
that I had to learn how to make my own
food and the fastest thing that I could
make was packaged ramen and today I'm
going to be eating the ramen that I
enjoyed a lot growing up as a kid but
with the grown-up twist now that I
cooked myself now for the first lobbying
packet that we're going to be eating and
that's what we call it in Korea Lanyon
japanese ramen in China the biggest la
yen I might as part of that [ __ ] but one
of the ones I love eating the most was
this one called no booty now nobody is
going to be a I guess if you guys had
something called sampling before it's
like a spicy seafood noodle dish and
this has a really great job of
replicating that um the noodles if you
had it before now actually before we get
into it let's talk about what I did to
this I always like to upgrade my ramen
so most people when they have ramen
they're like oh it's just a quick bite
to eat yeah that's true but it doesn't
mean that you can't spice it up with a
little bit of ganked this green stuff
right here that you see on top this is
actually called me naughty I don't know
what it is it might be Japanese parsley
or something like that
I take shrimp and then I sauteed in a
hot skillet with sesame oil and a little
bit of garlic and pepper I don't solve
it because the soup is re salty enough
as it
is and then with that I actually cook
clams
when I steamed them and then with the
clam juice actually put it back into the
sauce package with the water so it kind
of has like this climbing seafood taste
with it and of course in the middle you
are going to have this delicious yolk
right there so if you guys are watching
this you could check me do this to it
real quick bow you see that that juicy
delicious
ayyy yo Keem is right there now let's
take a bite into this we'll start with
the shrimp so long take those noodles
with that a little bit of that green the
me not even
oh yeah oh it's so good um me naughty
kind of has like it's definitely a
parsley taste it might be Japanese
parsley I'm not sure but I've grown up
eating this time in my whole life and I
remember when my mom would go to the
Korean market this would Ilana that
would ask for yes because these noodles
are a little bit different if you've had
like those American rounded packages
right then and you know they just take
like beef bullion and you can rob mint
packets are way different it's not the
same bite mm-hmm when I used to I used
to watch a lot of like cooking shows
when I was kid I'm specifically because
we didn't have cable and because we
didn't have cable one of my favorite
channels I used to watch was actually
the public was the public television
station which is a PBS PB I said a lot
of cooking shows and a lot of people
used to watch this just like chakras pan
Julia Child's yang Ken Cubs and these
people are the ones that um influenced
me a lot and never the ones that
actually got me the first cook my ramen
before my parents used to work like 80
hours a week or the business and I would
too but the days that I would stay at
home if my mom didn't make any food um I
would I think we make my own ramen and
they watching those televisions made me
want to cook to make my own ramen so it
really got me to be creative the stuff
that I was making you know
just because like it's like
quote-unquote cheese school doesn't mean
that you can't make it your own
you know alright huh there's something
about like a cook flash post a day
inside ramen brought that just to bring
all this stuff together
no oh here's the little clam buddy the
delicious clam buddy mm-hm
if you don't have a Korean market for
you to buy the nobody laniel you can
actually get this on Amazon which is
where I actually got mine and I'm not
saying I don't think it's cheaper per se
but you know if you don't want to go out
into the market and you just want to get
stuff right here doorstep Amazon Prime
this [ __ ] it's delicious
how many of you out there a trauma
growing up but you had to have eaten
ramen growing up
and not only is it like like a nostalgic
food for me and turnip like my childhood
this was actually college food so I
should when you're like a college
student and you also on the go and
you're low on budget when you need like
something bomb to eat that just kind of
like makes you feel like you're at home
make this ramen dish it's not expensive
but a dollar per pack if you order it
online or if you get it involved then
you just buy a couple of the other foods
or the other ingredients
and there you go you know okay [ __ ]
ramen sauce everywhere every wanting was
um so if you're wondering what kind of
pot this is this is like I guess is like
a chi get hot so GJ means like stew or
soup in Korean but a lot of people make
lime known in this and the reason why we
make lamb into this is because it's so
thin it makes the water boil extra fast
or if you're hungry get yourself a mom
in Thailand you got to wait you don't
have to wait for anything
we're being a little health-conscious
mm-hmm
ramen that might not be the best choice
for you if you have high blood pressure
probably not to this really hot really
salty I don't usually drink the soup
because yeah I have high blood pressure
in my family but I'm gonna do it anyway
[ __ ] this is the remnant of what
is less clam shell soup and
deliciousness and there you have it my
friends
nobody ramyun that next up is my new new
favorite favorite can we talk about how
delicious this London here is my friend
before we go ahead and start to let's
talk a little bit about the punch on
punch on for you guys who don't know in
Korean as side dishes and we are going
to start off with a little bit of [ __ ]
to you this got to be is very important
to me you know why it's because my mom
came here down for my birthday and she
made this for me into a big like tongue
where little you know container so the
lineman that we have here right now my
friend is a library called Shin Lam
young black and on your black is very
unique because the original [ __ ] not
meant that I used to eat did not taste
like this [ __ ] on your black is
different in the sense that it has a
second soup base within the package that
second soup base is consisted of so long
tongue flavor now the long tongue if you
guys don't know is like a beef bone
based broth that is it's very homey it's
kind of like stick to your bones like
food that you eat during the winter and
it adds like this creaminess to this
ramen that it didn't have before that's
why this is probably my new new top
favorite lemon of the moment so with
this log in right here I basically
sliced up these green onions very clean
on top so kind of add like this fresh
crisp like texture to it I fried up an
egg just to be different from the
poached egg that we had before I took
some slightly slightly [ __ ] some
Ben Lee sliced pork belly I fried it up
in a small pan at a salt and pepper to
it and right here on the side is the
game changer this is a slice
my friends of American cheese now I know
that might sound a little crazy to you
but when you add American cheese to
Lanyon it adds that creamy delicious
velvety like this fattiness to your
ramen that you didn't have before
so before you not get try it and you'll
thank me later
[ __ ] let's go ahead and dig into
this we're going to mix the cheese
flavor and I like to leave a little bit
of those chunks there just so I could
bite a little bit take some of the green
onion like so oh my god it smells good
oh my god if you could eat this right
now which you can because it's
relatively cheap but the flavor of this
is out of this world
it's creamy flavor pack is a little
spicy to top it off with these pickles
the factory which is the pickled radish
as a refreshing bite when we clean we're
going to take this a little bit at the
Friday and the ramen mm-hmm let me show
you the perfect bite no quick right
there green onion pork belly and
deliciousness so good okay I was going
to put the oh [ __ ] I'll go do it on
cable but over the last time I'll pass
the cable hold on tight this is a little
trick that my dad taught me apparently
all 20 people can open up a [ __ ]
bottle with a spoon but and kind of use
this as a lip top point and there are
those haha this is like the new Korean
beer on the block a lot of people are
used to drinking top height but cloud is
the new guy on the block that I am very
much enjoying it has a little bit more
flavor piping cost is a bit more crisp
in my opinion but to explain to my
people out there who aren't Asian what
this tastes like it would be like it's a
really good bud just with more flavor a
lot more crisp it just tastes way better
than button what if you don't know what
the noise is when Korean people drink
refreshing [ __ ] that's the noise that we
make beers with spicy delicious in onion
[ __ ]
now this is something you could really
impress somebody with I'm sorry because
somebody will eat your regular [ __ ]
right they'll eat it
he'll tell the girl any my mother making
this bomb-ass meal but it's going to be
packaged rum she'll laugh in your face
will lap right now [ __ ] cuz I'm not to
impress the [ __ ] out of your tastebuds
don't judge until you try the lek
cuisine French - no oh so good
[Music]
forgot to talk to you throughout this
whole thing um Cheers
shinomiya done lastly my friend is
another childhood flavor fragrant what
is going on I think I'm so full I can't
speak credit Leslie might say hey one of
my childhood favorites that actually
isn't a lament it is a version of cha
dong-young called kappa getting not just
a giddy for you guys who don't know is
based off this Korean or Chinese dish
called Adam Yan or I believe in Chinese
like thousand yen or some [ __ ] like that
I'm sorry not some [ __ ] like that so
there's two one that everybody knows I
said too but I got three fingers up
there's two one everybody knows it's
either Japanese or Java GUI Java Getty
is made with a dried soup base and then
you kind of take out all the water and
you just leave a little bit less than
what the starch content from the noodles
and then you get kind of this brown
saucy delicious goodness the stop saw
beauty one comes with a wet sauce so if
you don't actually have to leave any of
that extra moisture in there or
obviously comes a little bit too soupy I
prefer to forget it because I think has
better flavor
now with this one the only different
things that I did with this is I added a
little bit of sesame oil not too much
because that stuff is powerful and then
I sliced up little pieces of cucumber
just to add a little fresh bite to it so
my friends here we go it's a interesting
thing because this is it's not spicy at
all it's brown like Dookie so why did I
say that before meeting is so the flavor
profile of this is savory and sweet
oh yeah and once again top it off with
my mum back to thee first of all can I
just say this to those skinny little
Korean girl doesn't that do these
muffins I love [ __ ] you eat that much
I'm dying right now but it doesn't make
sense where does it go
how much do you poop I can only imagine
then we need that much food your toilet
must be a [ __ ] danger zone chewy you
move her a little bit the good edition
I'm in a lot of flavor
mmm plus again we're talking about a lot
of things when I was a kid because
there's a lot of kids food that I you
see only as much as an adult now because
well it's really not that good for you
but I would always actually mom to make
this with me because I couldn't do it
and what I found out once again like I
told you with the instructions on how to
make this
I wouldn't take out the water so I would
have always end up with soup and I was
like this doesn't make sense it then
tastes like mom's but I found out
eventually because my mom's probably
make it if she called me stupid this can
we get the hell out the way and stop me
or five smart enough I will just read
the [ __ ] package but I want what do
you guys think so for me do you guys
like sharing a meal with me having a
conversation and meeting I will tell you
this though I do enjoy eating with you
I'm thinking about doing this stuff live
but if I do it live I won't be able to
cook like multiple things for you you
just be waiting online not really my
thing
I would prefer just to cook the food
well have a playstyles run you let you
know the importance of the food and why
you didn't how to cook it and how to
make it good for you you know when I
grew up I used to uh my mom used to
always wonder why I like eating Lynam so
much cause you know she will make
home-cooked food for my towards the time
and I just always crave the stuff
eventually I'd stop with it because yeah
it's bad for you but I tell you man look
at this the golden stuff
come on Dom people who aren't Asian out
there you're looking at the stuffing
about yo why is these slurping moves on
these when he's eating well an alien
culture when you sleep your sleep when
you slurp your noodles is actually very
polite just kind of showing that you're
really enjoying your meal so if you're
doing this when you're eating your
noodles
you're basically spitting in their
[ __ ] face JA spaghetti done now I
know this is my very first month long I
might do another episode depending on
what you guys want to see do you guys
want to see you cook some of the food do
you want to see a step-by-step
instruction um what else do you guys
want to see me create and eat my buck
longer a little bit different I'm not
just going to be you know getting stuff
to go because if I get stuff to go that
kind of defeats the purpose of what I'm
doing which is like I don't like wasting
food I kind of prefer making food at
home
so what do you guys want me to cook some
more food that I eaten when I was a kid
that obviously isn't like packaged stuff
Korean food Japanese food or some of my
own creations let me know in the
comments below and
[Music]